je vous voit très quand même angoissé
tortillant les
mains par là vous êtes bien là ça va je
suis très très bien dites-moi vraiment
donc ce rôle de séducteur vous y
retrouvez parce que la séduction c'est
un mot qui revient quand même beaucoup
même oui oui vous aimez plaire bah oui
vaut mieux plaire que déplaire mais je
suis pas capable de faire n'importe quoi
pour plaire hein il y a des choses que
je ne ferai pas en me disant tiens je
vais faire ça ça plaira non ça je suis
pas capable je me Renis pas moi-même
pour plaire mais ce mot de séducteur me
fait me fait rire parce que ce côté
alors ça commence à se calmer quand même
parce que maintenant je rentre lentement
dans un âge respectable comment comment
bah oui alors bon ça va je m'en sors
encore s près correctement mais mais
enfin ça va je suis dans un autrage
encore plus d'atout de
charme non il faut pas croire ça mais
non ce qu'il y a surtout c'est que ça me
fait rire parce que j'ai acquis cette
réputation en jouant pratiquement neu
fois sur 10 des hommes trompés blessés
fragiles c'est peutêtre votre fragilité
aussi qui plaît au sûrement sûrement
sûrement peut-être puis disons que je
suis peut-être devenu avec le temps euh
moins lâche parce que la lâcheté estant
l'apanage des hommes et je dis bien des
hommes pas des femmes euh et ben je je
disons que je suis humainement de
meilleure qualité aujourd'hui que je
neétais il y a 30 ou 35 ans j'imagine je
trouve que la virilité d'une certaine
manière c'est la pureté et ça n'est pas
le coefficient de dilatation de l'engent
en question qui est pas inutile mais qui
est une banalité en tout cas je suis
heureuse de vous retrouver puisque je
vous ai
filmé il y a très peu de temps au moment
des fêtes de fin d'année en train de
préparer une cuisine gourmande de la
manger avec autant de gourmandis et
alors on voit tous vos proches s'accord
à dire que vous êtes un boulimique moi
je dis frénétique de vie mais de la
scène du du théâtre du cinéma de la
cuisine de la nourriture de tout non je
ne suis pas un bouimique c'est le
contraire chez moi c'està dire que je
comment dire si j'avais été raisonnable
si j'avais su suivi les bons conseils
qu'on ne s'est pas privé de me donner à
une certaine époque et qu'on continue
d'ailleurs toujours de me donner oui je
n'aurais jamais travaillé a que les gens
que j'estime parce que non seulement ça
ne me fatigue pas ça me nourrit si la
vie consiste à faire une chose qu'on a
pas
désiré que vous ditesign dans son propre
désir et qu'on attend lentement l'heure
de la mort très honnêtement je vois pas
pourquoi on vit ça ne sert absolument à
rien quand j'entre en scène quelle que
soit cette scène que soit une une scène
de cinéma de télévision ou théâtre
j'entre en
donc quand on me demande quand je vais
m'arrêter je réponds très aimablement
que je m'arrêterai quand je serai mort
puisque la retraite d'un acteur c'est la
mort donc c'est pas c'est pas le moment
d'arrêter au contraire alors Eveline BX
dit elle vous connait bien que vous ne
savez pas dire non si si je sais très
bien dire non pas du tout non je sais
dire non non non je vous demande bien
pardon j'ai appris à dire non parce que
je ne savais pas le faire ça c'est vrai
maintenant je dis non je dis pas non à
tout il y a des choses auquelles je dis
oui mais si je dis oui c'est parce que
j'ai envie de le faire je ne dis jamais
oui par obligation est-ce qu'il il a
envie de rattraper des choses comme le
dit François berléan lui il dit il a eu
c'est vrai que vous avez explosé à à 35
4 39 ans oui voilà et il dit il a
peut-être envie de rattraper des des
choses non ça n'est pas tout à fait ça
mais c'est normal qu'il puisse regarder
ça comme ça non c'està-dire simplement
malheureusement le temps passe quand je
vois ces images de que vous avez la
gentillesse ou la cruauté de me montrer
ma sœur et moi il y a il y a 50 ça vous
a fait plaisir ou pas alors plaisir oui
enfin oui dans un premier temps oui
après c horrible mais bon voilà c'est la
vie
toujours mais je je je veux dire par là
que voyz ça c'est terrible quoi bon
voilà en même temps c'est des souvenirs
merveilleux est magnifique cette photo
oui oui elle est très belle c'est c'est
1000 francs de récompense de Victor Hugo
monté par maréchal en 60 6 au Théâtre
des Célestins de Lyon si je m'en
souviens bien bon je veux dire que le
temps passe alors je n'ai rien à
rattraper j'ai simplement sachant
maintenant voyant ce petit morceau de
route traversant un champ plat au bout
duquel on ne voit rien où je ne voyais
même pas la ligne d'horizon il y a
encore quelques années maintenant au
bout de ce chemin je vois une tâche
c'est un butoir c'estàdire que la voix
s'arrête alors j'en suis encore à
distance respectable mais avant je ne
voyais pas qu'il y avait le butoir
maintenant je le vois donc vous étiez
finalement donc maintenant je ne oui ENF
je rattrape rien je brûle tout ce que je
peux brûler avant d'être brûlé moi-même
c'estd que je vis deux ou trois vies
dans la journée me disant que s'il me
reste 25 ans à vivre par exemple j'en
aurais vécu plutôt 75 que 25 mais je le
fais tant que je suis là je le fais pour
ça pas pour rattraper pour me pour me
bourrer la gueule ou pour me me me filer
une crise de foi de l'existence me
disant que en tout cas je n'aurais pas à
regretter j'aurais j'aurais pris tout ce
que je pouvais prendre en fait vous avez
pris conscience de cet arrêt inéluctable
et est-ce que ça vous renvoie à ce
premier arrêt puisque vous avez commencé
vous très jeune très tôt une carrière
qui s'arrêtait nette d'ailleurs à peu
près en en mai 68 au moment des
événements de 68 ça dû être une oui oui
normal mais ça a été une cassure ça vous
avez pris
peur c'estàd j'avais eu un rôle
principal à la télévision d'une émission
qui se passa en direct à l'époque qui
s'appelle en votre âme et conscience les
grand França qui vous acé et qui à
l'époque il y avait une seule chaîne ou
peut-être deux et là on a j'ai été
propulcé du jour au lendemain formidable
il y je sais pas qu' 20 millions de gens
qui ont vu ça donc le lendemain j'étais
une gloire nationale dans la rue ce qui
était étonnant pour un petit jeune homme
comme moi et puis après est arrivé Mai
68 et puis toute la France entière s'est
arrêtée et puis ça s'est arrêté pour
tout le monde et donc pour moi aussi ce
qui est tout à fait naturel mais après
plus personne de nouveau savait qui
j'étais ils avaient pas eu le temps
d'imprimer ça donc je suis reparti
pratiquement à zéro alors je m'étais pas
dit ça y est je suis suis une vedette
maintenant tout est Vié je m'étais dit
ah ben je vais enfin peut-être pouvoir
commencer à approcher des choses des
gens et puis ça s'est arrêté je me suis
retrouvé en train de faire pratiquement
de la figuration avec Christian Jacques
qui m'avait vu là-dedans qui m'avait dit
écoutez j'ai un petit rôle pas beaucoup
vous êtes tellement bien mais est-ce que
vous voulez bien faire ça j'ai
évidemment accepté et ça m'a remis les
idées en place je me suis dit bon benah
voilà hein il faut garder la tête froide
ça peut être comme ça ce métier-là c'est
déjà miraculeux que je puisse continuer
de travailler bon je fais aussi le
garçon de café dans les dans le café de
mes beaux-pents les parents de Florent
georgéti qui ma première femme et la
mère de mon fils et tout ça ça m'a ça
m'a plombé quoi mais j'ai eu la chance
de vivre à cette époque-là dans une
société où il y avait du travail ouis
pas comme aujourd'hui c'est vrai et je
me suis dit bon ben voilà c'est comme ça
apprends apprends à vivre avec ça et
remonte lentement la pente continue
continue bah tu pensais que tu allais
avoir des rôles comme ça bah non tu
repars avec des trucs beaucoup plus
petits qu'avant ça fait rien si ça doit
revenir ça reviendra c'est pour cela
qu'à l'âge de 40 ans lorsque vous avez
connu une vraie vraie notoriété vous
n'avez pas arrêté de travailler peur de
l'arrêt besoin de vous rassurer voilà ça
été il fallait continuer là il fallait
vous teniez le fil oui et puis oui sans
doute mais s'il y avait quelque chose à
rattraper comme dit mon mon pote Bert
berléan et là-dessus il a pas tort c'est
à C âge là que je l'ai fait c'est à 40
quand la notoriété effectivement
populaire la reconnaissance populaire
est arrivée je me suis jeté je me suis
bourré la gueule avec le cinéma et tout
ça et j'ai pas forcément fait les bons
choix mais après
tout ils sont pas si mauvais voilà cette
cette photo vous avez quel âge pierre
vous vous souz j'ai 16 ans ah 16 ans oui
j'ai 16 ans 1 pe non 17 je pense
peut-être ouais c'est mes premières
cétait leses premières photos d'acteur
j'ai une tronche pas possible
i je m'aime pas je m'aime toujours pas
d'ailleurs là alors franchement quand je
vois ça je comprends pourquoi je
m'aimais pas vous ne vous aimez pas ah
non pas du tout non physiquement jamais
jamais moins que jamais maintenant mais
enfin même je préfère plutôt la tronche
que j'ai maintenant que que celle-là
mais non non mais j'aime pas j'aime pas
je dé j'ai un vage un visage flas quuc
comme ça non mais enfin peu importe
c'est aucune importance ça c'est très
difficile de regarder estce que vous
vous êtes quand même habitué vous avez
plus à moi oui ah non pas du tout ah
mais pas du tout mais moins que jamais
aujourd'hui mais ça il faut surtout pas
prendre ça pour de la coquetterie Mo je
je le dis je enfin je le dis je le dis
mais il y a des tas de films que je ne
vois pas par exemple dans lesquels je
tourne et pourquoi parce que je supporte
pas je supporte pas moi je me supporte
pas moi j'adore voir les autres he j'ai
aucun problème avec ça moi c'est un
cauchemar je je souffre 1000 morts parce
que c'estàdire je voudrais pas avoir
cette tête là je pense régime que les
angles sont beaux ils sont tartes je
trouv j'aime pas ma voix j'aime pas
comme je joue parce que jamais je ne
vois ce que j'ai cru que j'allais avoir
fait jamais et vous aviez un modèle
physique oui comme physique alors ah
mais j'aurais voulu être àinon c'est de
notoriété publique ça j'aurais adoré
sérieux on peut tout dire d'ind Deon
sauf qu'il n'est pas beau et moi j'ai eu
la chance un jour au petit matin il me
dit mais je vous raccompagne donc on est
parti il faisait très beau il y avait
une espèce de petite brise comme ça et
on est parti tous les deux et du coin de
l'œil je le regardais ma'accompagnant il
est plus grand que moi beaucoup plus fin
le vent soufflait comme toujours pour
lui dans le bon sens c'est-à-dire que
c'estes cheveux étit merveilleusement et
je le regardais à la dérobée et je le
regardais traverser l'espace comme un
ange et je me disait mais c'est normal
que ce type ait eu la carrière qu'il a
eu c'est normal c'est absolument normal
mais simplement voilà moi si vous me
demandez à qui j'aurais voulu je voulais
rassembler à Alain Delon point ah voyez
aucune chance ressembl à quand on a
cette trbine là à 7 mois ou à 9 je sais
plus très bien mais vous êtes très
mignon arrêtez d'arrêter je suis une
grosse boulette arrêté
pierre c'est drôle ma mère me montrait
ça tri quand elle était vivante
triomphalement me dis mais regarde comme
tu es beau mon chéri mais c'est horrible
maman cette photo en l'air donc besoin
de vous rassurer alors besoin qu'on me
rassure qu'on vous rassure en permanence
sur vous-même
oui je ce serait mal de dire que c'est
pas sur moi-même et de dire NON je me
suis rassuré c'est pas vrai non non je
suis toujours je crois aussi peu sûr de
moi au fond je le vois bien donc je n
pas VO je vous vois très quand même
angoissé tortillant les mains non je
suis pas angoiss parce là vous êtes bien
là ça va très très bien si vous voulez
c'est normal REM des choses oui on parle
de tout ça donc forcément ça va taper
des choses chez moi qui sont encore très
bouleversantes et est peut-être plutôt
plus bouleversante aujourd'hui qu'elle
ne l'était il y a 20 30 ou 40 ans
puisque le terme lentement approche il y
a quelque chose là-dedans qui me déchire
donc je peux pas faire autrement
que que d'être déchiré par moment par
Briis par petite pincettes comme ça al
ça ça me bouleverse que c'est ma mère
mais c'est autre chose justement votre
mère mais c'est la femme de ma vie
évidemment personne ne peut prendre sa
place Eveline Bix peut prendre toutes
les autres places sauf celle-là non
celle-là personne person ne peut la
prendre et d'ailleurs personne ne l'a
prise et et à un point tel d'ailleurs
que j'emmène ma mère dans ma poche au
théâtre avec moi le soir hein et que
quelquefois même je je m'en sers je m'en
sers parfois même de la pire des
manières c'est-à-dire que quelquefois
quand le personnage le demande et quand
il doit s'abîmer ou se déchicter alors
l'image de ma mère intervient
immédiatement et je n'ai aucun effort à
faire ça me déchire dans la dans la
seconde et donc au fond j'ai sans doute
dû réenterrer ma mère ou retuer
apparemment ma mère des dizaines voire
des centaines de fois mais c'est ma
manière à moi de lui faire savoir que
non seulement elle n'est pas morte mais
qu'elle est vivante en moi à chaque
instant de chaque seconde de chaque
heure de chaque jour jusqu'au bout et
comme elle est partie
bah je suis comme un petit garçon qui
attend lentement qu'elle revienne et
évidemment elle ne reviendra pas bien
que je suis toujours été persuadé qu'un
jour je la recroiserai dans ma vie je
suis pas pas là-haut hein ici à un
moment donné je pense que je vais la
croiser un coin de rue je sais pas
pourquoi c'était absolument stupide sans
doute mais je suis absolument persuadé
de ça alors pourquoi j'en sais rien mais
elle m'a marqué au fer rouge pour
toujours ma mère et pourtant c'est un
c'était un ange et elle m'a marqué parce
que la douleur est
insupportablec et qu'à 64 ans je ne
supporte absolument pas de ne pas
l'avoir le matin et je dirais ça de mon
père quand il va partir il est encore là
lui mais ce sera sans doute la même
chose pour d'autres raisons et mon père
personnage plus complexe plus comme le
dit ma sœur très exigeant parfois dur je
n'emploie pas ce mot-là mais très très
entier très intolérant par moment il
disait que c'était que que vous aviez
même peur lors mon père lorsqu'il venait
vous voir au théâtre
c'est lui qui a voulu d'ailleurs que
vous soyez que vous so vou soit AR
qu'est-ce qui vous a apporté qu'est-ce
que votre mère vous a apport écoutz mon
père a fait l'acteur que je suis je
pense ou il a contribué ma mère a fait
l'homme que je suis ils ont chacun leur
part euh l'humanité qui est la
mienne à l'intérieur c'est ma mère qui
l'a faite et l'acteur c'est mon père
très belle photo là oui ça c'est un oui
c'est une photo qui a une grosse
vingtaine d'années voilà euh mais je lui
ressemble de plus en plus maintenant à
mon père je lui ressemblais pas encore
trop là à cette époque là mais
maintenant maintenant je lui ressemble
et vous avez eu du mal j'imagine à
quitter le le domicile familial bien sûr
avec un attachement pareilreé très tard
contrairement à beaucoup de mes
camarades avant l'heure oui oui parce
que les gens me disent mais quoi je
pourquoi voulez- que j'aille ailleurs
c'est merveilleux chez moi je je la
maison était est une une maison ouverte
sur tout et sur tout le monde je peux
amener mes petits amis on dort dans
l'appartement c'est merveilleux on est
en bonne intelligence il ne se m pas
mère qui s'occupait de tout Oui ilelle a
porté le petit déjeuner le
matin il y a aucune raison de bouger oui
non enfin c'était quand même dans les
années 60 c'était c'était très en avta
assez en avance quand même pour l'époque
avance c'était avant 68 mais c'était B
c'était la roulotte c'était
novos j'ai j'ai croisé Béard comme ça
j'ai vu débuter ginsbourg je peux dire
ça et Brel même donc une enfance
complètement heureuse très heureuse
sublissement
heureuse ça c'est un regret
aussi non je pasux un regret parce que
je vis avec non non non je l'ai dans ma
poche ça alors sans beaucoup d'argent à
la maison aucunent pas de fric mais
commei on' jamais aperçu on l'a jamais
vu on l' jamais vu j'ai jamais vu il
faisait je sais pas comment il faisait
j'ai pas compris comment il étent
arrivés à faire ça les deux gosses n'ont
jamais vu qu'il n'y avait pas d'argent à
la maison jamais c'est impossible et
vous alors en grandissant vous êtes dit
que vous iriez je serai l'homme qui
ramènerait l'argent à la maison oui oui
c'est je me suis dit ça j'ai été
travaillé ailleurs que dans ce métier là
d'abord pourquoi vous vouliez de
l'argent s'il n'en avait pas manqué
c'est la question que je me pose parce
que comme un certain nombre d'ados on a
beau être très très bien élevé par
moment on perd de vue des choses qu'on a
pas encore bien comprises et à cette
époque- là j'avais perdu de vue
l'essentiel c'est-à-dire que je voyais
les mes copains de classe qui partaient
en weekend avec la DS19 du père et nous
on avait pas de dessit pas de voiture on
avavait pas de maison de campagne et je
me disais et bien je seraiis celui qui
parce que ça me snobbait à l'époque bon
parce que j'étais con donc je suis allé
travailler dans une compagnie
d'assurance d'ailleurs qui reste un très
bon souvenir parce que j'ai rencontré
des G
dans le c'était votre premier métier
enfin premier métier puisque vous
faisiezou ça été mon premier métier
pendant 2 ans bon voilà je m'en sortais
plutôt bien d'ailleurs puis un moment
donné je me suis rendu compte que
c'était pas ma vie mais je regrette pas
cet épisode là non plus j'ai vu le monde
du travail ce qu'on appelle vraiment le
monde du travail avec des gens dont
l'univers serait celui-là sans doute
toute leur existence bon et est-ce que
ce pourrait être l'une des raisons
justement de ce travail acharné aussi
par moment sans doute oui et ça n'est
pas ce que j'ai fait de mieux parce que
effectivement au bout d'un moment on se
crée des besoins d'autres besoins et
puis et puis au bout d'un moment si on
si on ne se fait pas de temps en temps
un petit point sur soi-même c'est ce que
je dis on se regarde dans maants mon
grand qu'est-ce que tu es en train de
faire là tu fais ça tu as pas tellement
envie tu fais ça tu as pas tellement
envie non plus tu fais ça tu fais ça
pourquoi pour le fric pour pouvoir avir
ça pour avoir cette voiture là pour
avoir cette maison là P ce truccl mais
tu es en train de te perdre toi-même et
j'ai toujours eu la chance un de me
poser cette question et surtout vaêtre
entouré de gens qui m'ont autorisé à me
la poser mais pour le reste il est
inutile de prendre cette vie au sérieux
puisque de toute façon comme dit l'autre
c'est une aventure dont on ne sort pas
vivant et dans ce que vous dites c'est
quand même la disparition des êtres
chers qui est quand même plus voilà plus
mal douloureuse même si je sens que
votre propre disparition vous pose un
réel problème ça m'en pose un mais je
vais t j'imagine bien ça POS je vais
écrire des mots quand même parce
que quand ma mère est morte je suis allé
dans l'appartement et et on a été trier
les papiers ce qui est jamais très
marrant et je suis tombé sur des choses
comme ça et ça
m'a évidemment redéchiré bon j'ai
découvert un dessin que j'ai maintenant
chez moi derrière il y avait un mot
manuscrit de ma mère qui m'était adressé
que je n'avais jamais vu voilà donc je
l'ai garder ce mot et il m'a
fait beaucoup de mal et en même temps
beaucoup de bien parce qu'au fond c'est
c'est une trace absolument ind délibile
que tout ça a eu lieu et donc je ferai
la même chose avec mon fils euh pour ne
pas pour lui dire qu'il faut pas qu'il
ait
mal Frédéric et que s'ans doute je serai
quelque part pas je sais pas bien où
mais je serai sûrement quelque part ici
apparemment j'ai pas l'air d'être là je
serai quand même là la preuve c'est que
voyez elle est là donc je serai là donc
il faut pas qu'il ait mal euh donc je
mettrai des mots Frédéric qui est
peintre comme votre père oui oui oui
hein mais vous lui avez dit tout ce que
vous ressentiez vous parlez avec votre
fils oui bien sûr je parle avec mon fils
mais on parle pas trop de ça on parle
pas trop de ça quel genre de père
justement vous avez été avec lui bien je
suis un tueur je suis un tueur je suis
un tueur ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que je me suis pas occupé de lui sa mère
non plus d'ailleurs comme sans doute il
aurait fallu s'en occuper à un âge où
l'enfant le demande parce qu'on é en
train de se fabriquer nous-même comme
acteurs Florent georgetti et moi et
c'était normal donc il a été beaucoup
pris en charge par les grands-parents
comme souvent dans ces cas-là et
euh cet enfant que je chéris et qui que
j'adore il a appris à se faire une
carapace pour ne pas souffrir quand il
était en demande donc maintenant alors
c'est un enfant très formidable il est
flamboyant il a beaucoup de talent il
est il est on s'aime mais c'est moi qui
ai fabriqué ça je navait qu'à pas le
faire donc il a fabriqué quelque chose
pour se défendre il a eu sans doute il a
eu raison donc d'une certaine manière
j'ai été un tueur est-ce que c'est vrai
qu'elle a remise des Césars il n'a pas
voulu venir non lorsque vous on vous a
remis quand M il a regardé non non mais
il ça euh ça le il est Frédéric
hardarditi alors il est mon fils mais il
n'est pas le fils de Pierre hardarditi
voà il est le fils de Pierre hardarditti
pierre hardarditti mais il est pas le
fils de Pierre hardarditti ça ça
l'emmerde oui il a pas envie je
comprends très bien
quand je vous dis que je suis un tueur
je sais pourquoi c'est que que d'une
certaine manière il doit aussi lutter
contre moi c'est tout à fait naturel
pourquoi vous êtes devenu comédien vous
acteur oh mais je suis devenu comédien
d'abord pour ce que raconte jvis pour
d'abord pour qu'on me regarde pour qu'on
me regarde on dit oh c'est qui lui oh
bien voilà prend ça évidemment comme
toujours bien sû narcissisme d'abord
mais bien sûr et aujourd'hui alors quand
vous jouez en dehors du narcissisme
quand je joue je je je vis quoi voilà
ce que je ce que je m'étais promis à 17
ans a lieu et et et c'est exactement
pour ça j'ai l'impression que je vole
quoi c'est je je prends le monde dans ma
main je le serre et il et et il vient
vers moi parce qu'il a chaud là dans mes
bras c'est veut dire c'est a une
impression d'infini d'absolu et c'est un
pays où la mort n'existe pas ça n'existe
pas puisque quand ça s'arrête ça
recommencera demain pierre avec tout ce
que vous avez dit alors vous avez mis la
c'est trop je je le comprends bien non
mais vous avez mis quand même la barre
assez haute pour la compagne qui est à
vos côtés oui actuellement Eveline wig
depuis d'ailleurs combien plus de 20 ans
23 dans ce métier c'est c'est pas mal
hein honnêtement je pense que de notre
génération deux acteurs on est on est
les record MAM du genre oui oui parce
que comme visiblement c'est pas prêt de
s'arrêter mais je je je mets la barre
très haut mais elle m'a beaucoup aidé à
mettre cette barre là où où elle est je
dis qu'elle peut elle pourra jamais
prendre la place de ma mère je ne lui
demande pas d'ailleurs parce que c'est
c'est pas une place qui est à prendre
mais je sais plus qui disait oui c'est
Bernard elle Bernard Mura disait que à
tour à Tourou oui c'est ma femme c'est
ma maîtresse c'est ma meilleur ami c'est
mon meilleur compagnon de jeu euh c'est
mon enfant
euh ça n'est pas ma mère ouais c'est
c'est déjà beaucoup de faire tout ça
pour moi j'espère que je peux être dans
l'autre sens aussi ça fonction l'espère
oui oui je crois votre sœur Catherine
Arditti disait que votre botte secrète
par rapport à votre longévité de couple
c'est continue se séduire oui c'était
cette séduction permanente de l'un
vis-à-vis de l'autre oui pas seulement
mais c'est très important moi les jours
où je sors de chez moi où je ne lui plaî
pas ça va pas mais vous le savez ah ben
elle me le dit si je ne lui plais pas
d'abord à elle je ça ne va pas dans ma
vie ça ne va pas mais ça n'est pas la
seule chose la séduction c'est que je
pense que nous n'avons pas fini de de
nous parler
voilà on a des choses à se dire surtout
et à faire surtout ensemble d'ailleurs
pendant un temps vous ne diviez même pas
vraiment on a mis un temps fou à vivre
ensemble ou oui un temps fou mais
maintenant on vit ensemble mais avec un
appartement suffisamment grand pour que
chacun ait son territoire et avec un
territoire commun et on s'invite dans
nos territoires quand je vais chez elle
je frappe et quand elle vient chez moi
elle frappe c'est normal voilà et puis
des territoires on frappe pas parce
qu'on est dans le
un truc comme ça c'est très bien on a
parlé beaucoup de choses on n pas parlé
de votre engagement c'est un véritable
engagement non oui à gauche
oui je suis un enfant de gauche ça il y
a rien à faire et je serai jamais à
autre chose qu'un enfant de gauche je me
méfie maintenant profondément de ne pas
donner de leçon de morale aux autres
parce que ça c'est terrible et en
particulier quand on est un homme public
et un artiste mais ça n'est pas parce
que je suis un acteur que je que qu'on a
à m'interdire d'être un citoyen bon
alors je vois bien on sauve les ban je
comprends quand on sauve les banques on
sauve tout le système donc nous nous
sauvons nous-même sans doute je veux
bien de mettre le raisonnement mais on
peut pas ne rien faire pour des gens qui
à un moment donné crèvent la D ne
gagnent plus d'argent même quand ils
travaillent et qui dorment dans leur
bagnole c'est pas acceptable ça on est
dans un le 5è pays le plus riche du
monde on peut pas c'est pas acceptable
alors une fois qu'on a dit ça on a rien
dit c'est c'est c'est de la mouche je
m'énerve ça je vois bien je me réénerve
bon mais si la gauche dit et elle a
raison je crois sait que l'homme est au
centre de ces préoccupation et bien
alors qu'elle s'en préoccupe h hein
l'issu je ne suis pas membre du Parti
socialiste vous êtes quand même homme de
gauche on a inauguré un quai François
mitteran il y a quelques années et on
m'a demandé de venir lire un texte de
lui d'ailleurs j'y suis allé je suis
passé comme ça il y avait beaucoup de
journalist qui me disaient mais pourquoi
pourquoi vous êtes venu ou pourquoi vous
venez j'ai simplement répondu pour ne
pas être infidèle voilà quel est votre
principal regret pierre est-ce que vous
êtes un homme de regret non je'ai pas de
ravail alors vous avez dit toujours avec
cette hantise de la disparition
j'aimerais partir en arrière et
recommencer plus lentement j'ai dit ça
oui vous avez dit ça non j'ai tort non
j'ai pas envie mais en même temps non
j'ai pas envie de je voudrais pas
recommencer ça non non non non tout ça
c'est un parcours C c'est comme une
scène qui a été tournée ce morceau de
vie là il fait partie moi les 64
premières années de ma vie elles sont là
voilà maintenant j'ai autre chose à
vivre non non j'ai pas du tout envie de
recommencer donc vous êtes plus sage
qu'il y a 2 ans finalement vous étiez
plus
inquiet je suis toujours un
mais mais j'ai trouvé une autre manière
de me bourrer la gueule voilà au fond
non ou je suis pas tellement sage j'ai
trouvé une très bonne manière de me
bourrer la gueule voilà c'est-à-dire que
je dors pratiquement plus que je vis eu
ah non non je dors pratiquement plus ah
non non mais je dors vraiment je dois
perdre conscience entre 2h et 2h3 par
jour après je somn encore 2 he et puis
après voilà non c'est rien mais j'ai je
m'en fous j'ai pas besoin je repose mon
corps je repose mon corps voilà ça ça a
besoin de repos rester en prise avec la
vie par j'ai pas intéressante ça il se
passe rien ça passe rien j'ai toujours
raconté ça j'ai demandé un jour à ma
mère j'avais 7 ans c'est quoi la mort
elle m'a dit c'est comme quand tu dors
mais tu rêves plus donc ça m'a terrorisé
pour le restant de mes jours elle
pensait qu'elle allait me fait une
petite réponse comme ça puis je m'en
souviens encore quand je ne dors pas et
que le monde dort apparemment là aussi
je tient dans ma main il y a rien qui
vient parasiter et je le il est à moi je
le possède et c'est moi qui dirige son
rythme et pas lui qui dirige le mien à
cette heure-là dans ces heures-là donc
je suis le maître du monde voilà je suis
un père assassin je suis le maître du
monde je suis je suis pas boulimique euh
je vois le
butoir je me porte encore pas si mal
voilà et je ne veis pas me faire lifter
demain ah alors je lui dis clairement
mais ça vous l'z vous l'aurez bien
compris vous l'aurez vu je le dis
franchement à la caméra je ne suis pas
lifté parce que sinon j' temp vous dire
qu'il faudra emprisonner le mec voyez
bon voilà et pourquoi vous dites ça non
je dis ça parce que je vois ça comme ça
temps perarditi s'est fait lifter et
bien non ça se voit bon donc c'est une
annonce
nationale sur une grande chaîne une
heure de grande écoute je ne suis pas
lifé non c'est une beauté naturelle
c'est une dégradation naturelle on va
dire et et donc je vous disait pierre en
fait au centre du monde exactement comme
lorsque vous étiez enfant bébé oui avec
le sentiment que le monde vous
appartenait ah mais il m'appartenait car
j'étais le maître de ma mère d'ailleurs
j'étais j'étais son roi je pouvais faire
absolument ce que je voulais ce qui
était d'ailleurs pas très bien
franchement mais bon voilà je me suis
très très bien arrangé avec cette
histoire finalement oui finalement voilà
c'est peut-être le seul avantage de de
l'âge qui avance c'est que si on a pas
été trop bête et pas trop tourner sur
soi alors on peut c'est absolument
délicieux d'avoir toutes les générations
autour que ce soit des amis de la
famille truc comme ça qu'on peut réunir
ça en se disant bah voilà on est
ensemble et c'est un moment on traverse
cette géographie momentanée là ça c'est
absolument délicieux et pour la au moins
troisème fois vous avez refait ce geste
qui sera qui sera votre geste finalement
ce geste
maternel et bien c'est vous
c'est vous qui l'aurez
provoqué pour ne rien manquer sur ma
chaîne Ina mire dum abonnez-vous et
activez la
[Musique]
cloche